um yeah I've never been on this street
before I have no idea who you are I have
a Shiva you knew named Hadley and I love
her and I take her on a walk every
morning kind of go in the same places
and today is a really beautiful day
outside in February it's like 67 degrees
I have a little extra time for before
work so I figured I'm gonna let her walk
me I'm just curious to see where she
takes me if I learned something new
about her honestly yeah I have no idea
where she'll take me before we do this
we gotta set up some ground rules one
you're gonna be in charge of where we go
but two you will not be allowed to step
into traffic will not put you in an
unsafe situation ready to go
[Music]
she's taking us on our normal route
sadly are you confused this is maybe
gonna teach me a lot of patience because
I'm like why are you just sitting there
but she's walking now I'm going this way
well happily seems to want to sit do
some people watching she got up but I
don't think she knows where she wants to
go nope this way I think we're headed to
a park
we don't go to this park that often at
least on during the week because it's
kind of far
we've been walking like an hour and our
player boarding walks our half hour I'm
tired
where are we happily if you take us
yeah I'm just waiting while she takes us
it makes me kind of self reflect that
she's making me stop while she smells
the roses or in this case dead grass I'm
gonna try to just sit and people-watch
with her in this dirt pile eat a little
to let her know I'm cool with leaving
like no pressure
the Masters I do feel closer to her I
feel like we're listening to each other
more have no idea who you are hoping she
like knows a better way home and I don't
know about it do you know where we are
you gonna try to not use my Google Maps
or anything because I want to trust in
the Sheep might be really good yeah I've
never been on the street before when I
recommend this at this point in that
journey now we're back to the straight
same street corner that we came from so
maybe she's not taking us home and I was
just hopeful
maybe she doesn't know how to get home
probable because she's a dog now I've
been doing this for two hours home yeah
[Music]
the street that we're on I think we're
going home am i proud of my impatience
now it's a red light
it's about the journey not the
destination right had they
[Music]
so we're back from our adventure it was
two and a half hours he listens to me
more than I thought and waits for my
cues which is really good also I need to
maybe stop brushing it was nice to just
like kind of take a stick in the park
and people watch before work we can
learn a lot from dogs I know I'm a crazy
dog person but like okay just fish how
cute is she would you do it again I mean
I think that as a baby
[Music]